sir uh all of us at collider are big
fans of your work I just want to say
thank you for everything you do well
thank you so episode seven which we got
to see some of earlier today uh it seems
like seven and eight are going to be big
um uh things for your character and the
storyline of Mandalorian uh what do you
want to tease fans about what they can
look forward to oh well you know they
can look forward to MAF goody and sort
of making taking huge steps to enact
um what he wants to accomplish
and so you might be able to see Beyond
the Veil and really get an idea I mean
we haven't really seen what he really
wants he wants the child you get an idea
maybe he wants to experiment maybe he
wants to do other things but you'll
start to
get with the science and of moth's brain
and so hopefully you know you're gonna
enjoy what he's cooked up and what he's
thinking about uh what do you think fans
will be saying when episode 8 ends oh
holy yeah holy
yeah I think it's going to be quite a
surprise to many of the fans like what
what really is happening you know you
see a little teaser today Mark Gideon's
very Democratic he's you know he's with
the council trying to bring people
together you see you know Rob thrown out
there you know in a way that could
relate to other shows possibly but he's
not with us and so you see people you
know relying on and trying to figure out
you know who is going to be that
all-powerful leader and uh right now you
got MAF Gideon who's in the mix you know
he's back he's back after having been
you know I'm shuttered for a little bit
he's obviously escaped and obviously has
ideas
um how to divide and conquer my last
thing for you uh what do you think would
surprise fans of the Mandalorian to
learn about the making of the
Mandalorian
I love that she is well they may be
surprised to learn that I do all my own
stuff how about that you know you know I
love physical action and I love you know
kind of the the dance of the fight and
so they might be surprised to know that
every frame of what I do
that's actually really cool
um on that note I got to let you go
because I have a two question limit but
I asked three so I'm just gonna say
thank you so much I really can't wait to
see where it goes my pleasure thank you
very excited amazed
and enchantments